[Music]
I'm a big fan of big little lies I'm so
excited you guys finished shooting
season 3 we're in the middle what can
you tease for us oh my no yeah I can't I
can't say anything I mean come on I
would get in so but struck true shailene
woodley keeping mum on big little lies
season do what she did gush over new
edition Meryl Streep she's so so good
that period and she's so humble I think
the thing the reason why Meryl Streep is
is Meryl Streep as she approaches a film
set as if it's the first character she's
ever played she never stops asking
questions to understand her character
deeper and on a molecular level she's
constantly challenging things in
positive ways to bring more to enlighten
all of us not just herself on the story
and the characters and the relationships
and I've learned a great deal from her
about acting and I feel like I'm working
with an acting coach in a way what's it
like having dinner with her that must be
like so cool you know at the end of the
day like you take your work clothes off
and you're just another human being
having a human experience for big little
lies comes out Shailene stars and adrift
alongside hunger game stars do you want
to say crow anytime you think you might
wonder who's hanging
[Music]
Hurricane Raymond has been upgraded to a
category five don't worry
who did better with the seasickness I
heard you dimitra's barf you did better
than me I feel like at least you could
barf yeah I could a tactical chunder
well it's something I'm very very
familiar you just kind of sneak off you
sick and then you're able to come back
and carry on drinking no pre-production
on and yeah I didn't make it
[Music]